okay there it is
hey what's going on everybody first we
feed I'm Sean Evans and you're watching
hot one it's the show with hot questions
even hotter wings and today I'm joined
by the Fupa Lord Himself Wow inclined
you can catch him on the best channel on
YouTube h3h3 productions not to be
outdone by the always entertaining Ethan
and ela and today we're going to figure
out how he is with spicy ass chicken
wings so then that was all really nice
thank you did you see you call this the
best Channel it is the best channel
that's really flattering thank you how
are you with hot food I'm pretty good
with hot food as a young young lad I
used to enjoy enjoy eating hot food more
than today but I remember once when I
was like 25 I ate hot food and my ass
will burn that was the first time it
ever happened and it was like the the
corpse got popped up and since that day
I've been you know I feel it you ready
to feel it one more time yeah I'm gonna
feel it today boy
all right so the first one sriracha
scratches no big deal I might as well
enjoy this one just want to start by
talking about YouTube because you've
been kind of a junkyard dog scrapping it
out on those streets for years
what is the dumbest YouTube trend going
on right now I can't do anything right
now
but the that don't judge me challenge
goes down is probably the dumbest thing
that's ever propped up on YouTube who's
the best youtuber of all time in your
opinion filthy Frank he's so on PC
he's so obscene he's so shunned by
YouTube but he succeeded like against
all the odds of having the most fun
Disney Channel on YouTube and he just
felt like sheer will made it carved out
this obscene space he's like the father
of all comedy uses I want to talk about
dj khaled for a second because I know
you know in me very much a mythical
figure in Horror Show and he's very much
a mythical right here in your channel I
know that you're trying really hard to
meet him for a long time yes and then
you were able to track him down
can you talk me okay because in my mind
that's one of the most surreal videos on
your channel it is surreal get a little
spicy coming up early I'm high travel
dude I'm already having burps [ __ ] you
showed him yeah a documentary and I
thought you know like kind of to his
credit he was pretty cool about every
hugely to his credit I'll say okay I
made fun of Khaled so much and I went to
his house and I kind of [ __ ] made fun
of him he may hate me after that video
aired but I'll say this to him and his
crew class acts though other parts were
so [ __ ] awkward and cringe II didn't
like it was unbearable to watch so we
cut out I think the video was like seven
minutes we show them the whole thing and
I think we cut out six minutes of it
because it was just [ __ ] like bad
[Music]
I seen you in that video with that goofy
German guy
we realized that [ __ ] was [ __ ] one of
my favorite videos on YouTube that guy I
like when he downed it and he's like
talking about how he likes the flavor
and start a cupping I think it's a
little bit Oh hook the - an avian
discussion
[ __ ] amazing good if you guys don't
know what that is watch that legendary
so dovetailing off the dj khaled
question i'm going to talk about living
means because you seem especially
fascinated by these characters whether
ten bone or MattyB or its Pappajohn and
you've had the chance to meet some of
these people face to face but i imagine
that there's some fish out there that
you're still trying to catch white
whales the number one is hop Papa John's
net nerd he's a he's the white whale and
if the problem was shattered
Papa blessed is that he's so [ __ ]
rich like the guy doesn't give a [ __ ]
about me it's like an unattainable dream
I don't think I'll ever catch that white
well his living name status it's so
chiseled into the marble of our legacy I
just love to meet him I'd like to sit
down and have a pizza with him and bow
and maybe some soda pop alright so this
one's the Queen majesty it's a nice name
very lofty mm-hmm black coffee
so I want to talk about super laws 2017
for a second because the chopping talk
doesn't seem to be as thick as it was
nope this time last year what sorts of
lifestyle changes are you making to draw
that thing back a little while eating
deep fried wings but here's the trick
you code it and basically toxic amounts
of spicy so now you not only [ __ ] this
out but everything goes in your body so
eating high peppers we did taking
laxatives lots of laxatives is good have
you ever thought about maybe just going
for a height or like y'all watch it but
I'll know dude why would you say that
actually that's another group I have a
kind of body where I'm fat and skinny at
the same time which is kind of [ __ ] up
people are look at me they're like
you're normal and I take off my shirt
and they're like no dude you're not
normal I feel bad for a heel I'm like
how to achievement layer hands-free
[ __ ] monster that has been going on
for a while it's like self-loathing
sexless
well the first thing I did is just cut
the portion huge eating like oatmeal
hard-boiled eggs steamed broccoli I hate
my life but I'm losing with this nice
basically thank you for great alright so
the next part of the show is called
explain that gram we did a deep dive on
your Instagram pulled interesting
pictures that need more context I'll
buff out the laptop show you some pics
and you tell me the bigger story so I'm
good
well I mean I love this segment when you
do it but for me I'm thinking about my
Instagram I'm like yeah if there's
anything interesting there I don't want
to talk to you about this nice for a
second yeah you know you do all these
things in public that I you know draw so
much attention to yourself because like
you're always making yourself like this
big character in public it's humiliating
yeah I hate it we kind of stopped doing
it because it's so soul-crushing I think
the worst one we ever did where I walked
around very tan I put on like 50 layers
of tanning I look like I was in
blackface
like it was just racist and people were
like this guy's not for real this guy's
a [ __ ] lunatic go to the beach and
pashutin stay in the side it looks like
you have jaundice um that was the most
humiliating I've ever been so let's talk
about this vapenation picture for a
second because with me with episode
sometimes I'm like oh this one's going
to be huge and then maybe it like
performs a little bit under my
expectations other ones I don't have
high expectations when they go through
the roof right where was your mind on
vapenation did you think vapenation
would be a huge mega hit that's a that's
such a great question because we really
thought this was a shitty video because
when we were out in New York City we had
no [ __ ] plans and everything just
kept happening like our interaction with
the police the police officer who let us
sit in his car the bait store there were
those kind of like amazing the news
anchor and then that was like the cherry
on top
vapenation on the news represent the
nation y'all
Hey
looking back on it now I think it's our
best video but it's like I can't even
take credit for it who's the babe gods
dude like seriously shining down on you
for real good little blueberry I want to
talk to you about birthright for a
second because every time I've ever
talked to somebody about birthright they
always have a funny story about
birthright but first without boohoo
don't know what it is can you explain it
well his breath right um
birthright is when a bunch of rich
Jewish Zionists pay a bunch of young
Jewish kids to go there it is that one's
a little spicy and then the cliche about
it is that it can be kind of this like
hormone driven robbed like kind of like
a mini sort of Spring Break I [ __ ] like
crazy
bo Derek so I'm a killer there I know I
know I was and your experience is a
little bit different I was just I was a
young kid dude I was out there is my
first trip out by myself and either was
a soldier and there's really army dude
they're so conniving they do this on
purpose
they bring these beautiful people young
Israelis from the army to mingle with
you you know sparks and romance and get
your ass to move there right mm-hmm do
they handpick like beautiful people they
do yes they do
you look Synovus definitely like they
get the most beautiful people there but
a backfired on them because I took her
out of Israel now they're now they're
crying
[Music]
cheers Cheers
oh you got I got the big one I got to
eat them all I feel like it's a shame to
waste food that's your cross to bear you
know hopefully so what I want to do is
show you some of the biggest youtubers
in the game some people who bubble up in
the news every once in a while and then
I just want to get your snap reactions
on them I want to know if you pass or
smash you want me to post it Oh a
channel in the channel I don't care
about if you talk I'll tell you a bow
yeah I'm going to tell you if I [ __ ]
them and if I like the channel that's
perfect hmm listen [ __ ] my teeth and do
some big grills here the first one goby
person Coby person garbage absolute
trash just [ __ ] trash fake social
experiments I feel like they don't even
plan their views they just like okay
let's go to New York find a minority
punch him in the face and see what
happens it's like I feel like they don't
even really think about what they do
next is jenna Marbles jenna Marbles I
have so much respect for because women
have it really hard on YouTube when and
just get the most horrible comments so
she's not only like endured that forever
but she's one of the og youtubers and
she's still getting a ton of views and
making great videos love her smash next
is Vitaly Talley well you got the whole
usual suspects Vitaly is kind of [ __ ]
off lately did you know he was in a porn
and couldn't get it up did you see that
it was a bang bus that she was on bang
bus and he couldn't get it up that's the
best thing he's made and I bang him
through that I bought I dubs his content
is next slowly he'll like put aside a
month of his life to be like I'm gonna
make this video amazing I have a ton of
respect for idubbbz would definitely
smash can I ask you about people who
aren't on YouTube and then kind of go on
YouTube I want to talk about mainstream
celebrities you know did I play I
launched a YouTube channel like the rock
you know he'll make some big
announcement that he's going to make a
YouTube channel
great push I hate I think it's just
really cringey because they're like it's
different worlds I don't like what the
rock does because I feel like it's just
really arrogant he's trying to get
something he didn't earn and YouTube is
like trying to it just feels like their
entire
and their stuffs not good and you to
promote them and make videos with them
they're in every single video and it's
like this get off my [ __ ] [ __ ] have
you ever had someone come and eat all of
them yeah all I meet mm-hmm I'm gonna do
that love it love it
look at this champion this one tastes
good
you like the bomb yeah well you don't
like it that's probably our most dogged
on soft look no toler's won't look at
you there are some bad ones in here give
me on it hot ones no that no that one
not that definitely not that one that
one's spicy but maybe I should yours
your experience here yeah I'm not a
superhero
this is a you know I'm just a normal guy
well I'm surprised that I can see you
suffering because usually it just seems
like you're like cool this is my life I
love talking about this alone packaging
this alright so there are times when I'm
dying right and it's in the cut and
people are like I hate when Sean fakes
like he's struggling Syrians they think
that I'm trying to like win over little
gas and sympathize with them you know
it's such a conspiracy situation what a
mythology you have but then on top of
that if we showed me struggling all the
time I feel like it would get old so the
people that tune in every week it's you
know how many Shawn reactions yet so you
don't really see Shawn Eaton you don't
really see Shawn reacting right like who
gives a [ __ ] you know no yeah that's a
really good point of thing but I think
it's comforting at least to see you
suffering and you're not like that one's
really hot dude I am I'm wound to our
lives that one's really [ __ ] hot I
don't know about eating the whole I'm
gonna take a Bible oh remember that
remember that chatter that you had there
a second ago
bullies I mean this one's got to be a
lot hotter than this one right yep and
then this one's hotter than that one and
then there's some tighter than that one
but you know what I feel like if you can
handle this you can kind of handle this
but this one's actually to me to
toughest one that really mad dog just
because of what we're seeing a stuff is
the way things hit you in the way
things most of the [ __ ] spiritual
aspect of it okay I'm feeling better you
are it's way off I uh
whoo I'm really I'm good so I want to
talk about YouTube beef for a second
because I feel like if I say something
rude about a celebrity or about somebody
I feel like there's probably a 25%
chance that it gets back to that
person's ears but I think that with you
there's a 100 percent of the time you're
going to hit your target situation which
is interesting because I wasn't always
the case when we started we had under a
hundred thousand subscribers we were
blasting all these pranksters we s
always wonder I really wonder if they
saw it or we make a video but Papa John
really wonder if he saw it I was really
like excited mm-hmm
so a hot one mm-hmm that's the shot hot
ones kind of ensuring this much milk in
[ __ ] years dude of all the people and
channels that you goofed on over the
years who's had the strongest reaction
well obviously there's one guy that I
think a lot of our fans know his name is
like Voldemort
you can't say his name or I'll [ __ ]
sue you so we'll talk Louis he's bold a
company that you goofed up who's maybe
one over your respect with how well they
kind of roll with the punches is there's
somebody down handled the joke early
that happens a lot I love when people do
that and that's like what we call
embracing the meal there's this guy
recently Connor Murphy who he goofed on
and he made a video where he went out to
the street and did like a Smasher pass
if you can just make a funny video and
response don't sue me don't come to my
house don't threaten me just [ __ ] eat
words with words speech was speech dude
all right are you ready to move on I
guess did I header yeah I'm good for Mad
Dog 357 we're going to bring out a very
special guest
[Music]
Keela welcome to the table and you know
what I feel a little bit uh like you're
the the cards are stacked against you
right now because usually you can kind
of work your way up to something and let
the record show I was like you know I
don't want to eat any wings you don't
have to getting wings can you chill but
let the record show you it was like she
I want to see only good wings I want to
try the mad dog I want to try the Blair
finish the show up with Ethan and he'll
up at first let's take a bite out of a
wing
well I we're doing it yeah that's the
one you want and I'm lame like I need my
care here so Cheers I don't think you've
ever you name famous places like a
high-tension belong yeah flavors BAM
mmm-hmm brother dog food right off the
bat
oh my god I'm not I was very foggy I
gotta tell you right now I'm okay but
I'm expecting the pain to come you good
I'm okay
you all right look biting Ethan you're a
man of many trademark a bunch and roll
the chubbin talk the bunch mole but I
think that it's the beanie that kind of
cements your place as a style icon what
I want to do now is play a little game
called
who wore it better be me edition what
I'll do is I'll show you a couple of
other high profile beanie fanatics
celebs who are always wearing beanies
and then you tell me who wore it better
okay I'll just go to the side-by-side
you guys work together yeah I ready
let's go first up
Rihanna vs. Taylor Swift Rihanna
microphone yeah by far she's wearing it
in the classic nipple the nipple style
which is when you don't try to make it
look good
you don't try to [ __ ] with it you put it
on it nipples up and you embrace it I'm
she's got a neon color bright green
nipple past Taylor Swift is is sitting
in Baltimore Lee kind of like West
Mountain Bobby mom Lisa the reggae this
to me looks like grandma
trying to be hit with it when you try to
be hip with the beanie you fail next we
have jay-z vs Diddy oh [ __ ] what do you
say I know my answer for sure
I think jay-z really now you're gonna
say I knew okay why do you like jay-z
traitor
just no way pull the whole look together
so you like the actual fashion of it
because again I'm going with the guns a
little on the side like you pull a
beanie right above the eyebrows you're
doing two GU which is interesting
because he's probably wearing like a
half a million dollar jacket look at so
I don't know P Diddy is really falling
it off for me Bieber vs Robert at first
Twilight boy oh well my answer is just
so [ __ ] easy I can't wear I can't
believe people wear the beanie like
Justin is are not like I'm ironic he
looks like a smurf looks [ __ ]
ridiculous that being said I love it
Bieber is Venus to team yeah I don't
like I don't like the Tin Man John
Legend and Chrissy Teigen or Ethan in
you know what do they do
who are they are they like super famous
I don't know I loved her but I'm like I
miss something
beanie games pretty good I feel weird
picking our side weird it's not fair but
yeah I wrote the book on the beanie game
obviously we're wearing it better sorry
John Legend whoever you are but you're
making it look so easy
the last one was not that the one before
of Miami up oh we're going to dab it
right a dab will do you all right Ethan
Anila this is Blair's mega dust bath
with liquid rage it is tradition around
here put a little dab on the last wing
you don't have to if you don't want to I
will pass it around I don't have to if
you don't want to but I'm going to put
extreme peer pressure and I'm going to a
million you let everyone know what a
[ __ ] you are you know you don't have to
I get it
but be careful even that jiggle move
that you just have is making me a little
nervous
that's a leaky oh [ __ ] I thought okay I
thought it was now what kind of [ __ ]
idiot makes the hottest sauce in the
world without it a little dabbing I
don't know that's a fair point
one
[ __ ] Blair Blair [ __ ] you Blaire it
was ruined my day dude well okay it's
very biscuits it's coming right out
oh that's good that was not a good
textbook dab right there mid Navin for
years
well you Tereus is really had some time
house just line up right Rama
nice and slow oh wow so great you ever
seen daddy and like everyone alright
this this is gonna hurt alright Cheers
cheers Cheers cheers Cheers
I'm telling my heartbeat like going up
I just take the down-low spine right
yeah killed it great job Ethan
we probably mourn that gap let me check
the box I made cube now but I'm fine
I've said it once I'll say it again you
know hot sauce it's sort of the truth
serum when it hits you it unlocks
something deep down inside of you and
you to our couples goals through the
roof but we all know that it's not
always paradise okay Wow really we're
gonna take her here huh so we're going
to have a little Blair's Megadeath sauce
couples therapy question but I'm kind of
gonna focus it on Neela Oh Neela I'm
scared
what is Ethan's most annoying quality
okay holy [ __ ] Oh God God cut cut
Ethan can sometimes losing [ __ ]
very quickly from something very stupid
like is I fine not starting something I
push the button you turn on it's a
simple exchange like I can handle it I
can handle it it's like was puck good
way to do is make no apologies she makes
it my responsibility to figure out what
for her to hear she's like I said you
want this you want this you want me a
girl you choose you want me to make you
age you want me to go okay so no I don't
feel like that I don't feel like that I
like [ __ ] bend backwards to kind of
put some meat on her her dad says her
dad says to me before we leave Israel he
goes make sure she gains weight just
says [ __ ] Jochen on my word of honor
and then when she has nothing to eat she
gets mad at me she says you never try to
help you figure out what to eat it's
like that's literally all I think about
Bing Bing Bing you guys made it through
Ethan it was amazing
ela would you assist URI ally very Kobe
Shaq over here I have to say I'm really
impressed with you coming in
donut yeah no joke real tip and beanie
on out will MVP I had something become
such a fan of the show oh and we love
this show
we're honored Missa it's a mutual love
fest here in a very real and clear way
this camera that camera that camera but
the people know what you have going on
in your life I got nothing I just came
here for lunch I'm hungry
no why I got nothing promote I'm here
because I love this show I love Sean
heavens
watch this show don't watching me just
keep watching this that's my book
[Music]
be ok thanks preparing should we take
another bite
no hey what's going on hot ones fans if
you like the video maybe meet us halfway
throw us a subscribe if you didn't like
the video don't subscribe I don't want
you I don't want you in the tent but if
you liked the video subscribe thank you
very much I appreciate you I love you
more than a friend